sur le plan judiciaire en france verdict
attendu aujourd'hui pour une infirmière
poursuivi pour violence contre la police
elle avait lancé des projectiles en
direction des forces de l'ordre à
l'occasion d'une manifestation de
soignants c'était il ya un an
deux mois de prison avec sursis ont été
requis contre cette infirmière elle est
visée pour outrages violences et
rébellion contre les forces de l'ordre
écoutez là je suis là pour les malades
qui est beaucoup plus attention mais
comme je le souhaite
le piquetage ça concerne tout le monde
donc si on continue à ce rythme là on ne
pourra plus fonctionner dans les
hôpitaux publics
merci beaucoup et on va retrouver tout
de suite notre reporter mona amoud et
l'or devant le palais de justice à paris
[Musique]
bonjour mona vous allez suivre
évidemment ce verdict qui va tomber ce
matin on imagine pour eux cette
infirmière
que faut-il attendre de cette audience
mona
et bien c'est aujourd'hui que farida va
être fixé sur son sort deux mois de
sursis ont été requis par le parquet de
paris au terme d'une journée d'audience
et qui s'est déroulée le 22 février
dernier une journée qui avait été
d'ailleurs marqué par une importante
mobilisation pour farida qui devait
répondre des faits d'outragés de
violence et de réveillon contre les
forces de l'ordre
farida avait précédemment eu l'occasion
de s'expliquer sur son geste souvenez
vous le 16 juin dernier lors d'une
manifestation de soignants qui était
organisée pour dénoncer les conditions
de travail difficiles en plaine et crise
du coc vie des biens farida expliquera
avoir jeté des projectiles en direction
des forces de l'ordre sans jamais et les
insultes et c'était un geste symbolique
avait-elle dit
pas d' insulte et surtout pas elle ne
voulait pas blesser intentionnellement
les forces de l'ordre rapidement
les images de son interpellation assez
violente musclées avaient été sur les
réseaux sociaux et avait créé
l'indignation
on la voyait alors à genoux dans un
groupe de policiers vêtus et de sa
blouse blanche alors l'audience commence
à 9 heures et ce n'est pas vraiment un
procès puisque aujourd'hui et bien
farida sera simplement fixé sur son sort
deux mois de sursis ont été requis et on
suivra pour vous cette audience
merci beaucoup mona mona hamou dès lors
en direct du palais de justice à paris